DOWN TODAY.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: INTERESTING
PATCHWORK.
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANKS FOR
THAT.
THERE’S BEEN SO MUCH GOING ON
RECENTLY IT’S EASY TO FORGET IT
BUT THERE STILL A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN GOING ON.
UNTIL A FEW HOURS AGO THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARIES WERE STILL
IN PROGRESS.
BUT NOW IT’S DONE, AT LEAST
OFFICIALLY.
THIS MORNING BERNIE SANDERS
DROPPED OUT OF THE RACE.
>> WE ARE NOW 300 DELEGATES
BEHIND VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
OF THE PATH TOWARD VICTORY IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
SO TODAY I’M ANNOUNCING THE
SUSPENSION OF MY CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: SO THAT’S IT FOR
SANDERS.
HE 78 YEARS OLD AND WILL NEVER
BE THE PRESIDENT BUT HE DID
LEAVE HIS MARK.
FOR TWO CYCLES IN A ROW
BERNIE SANDERS EVOKED PANIC AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS AT THE DNC.
TWICE IN A ROW DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LEADERS SPANISH TO CRUSH HIM AND
THEY DID THAT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THEY HAD A LARGE AND
PASSIONATE FOLLOWING DESPITE THE
FACT OF A LARGELY POPULIST
MESSAGE.
THE DNC OF MEANWHILE IS OSSIFIED
AND CORRUPT AND CARES NOT AT ALL
ABOUT THE ACTUAL LIVES OF ITS
VOTERS.
SO HOW DID THEY MANAGE TO BEAT
HIM TWICE?
THEY COULDN’T HAVE DONE IT
WITHOUT SANDERS’ HELP.
SANDERS NEVER WANTED TO WIN,
LIKE SO MANY IDEOLOGUES HE
WANTED TO LOSE, IT MAKES HIM
FEEL VIRTUOUS.
IN 2016, HE DIDN’T GO AFTER THE
GROTESQUE SCAM THAT WAS THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION UNTIL IT WAS
FAR TOO LATE TO MATTER.
THIS YEAR HE DISAVOWED ONE OF
HIS OWN SUPPORTERS FOR
CRITICIZING JOE BIDEN AND THEN
FLOYD LEE PRAISED BIDEN’S
CHARACTER.
THEN SANDERS STOPPED BY LIKE AN
EMBARRASSED CHILD IS
ELIZABETH WARREN ON CNN ATTACKED
HIM AS A SEXIST.
AFTER A WHILE THE VOTERS BEGAN
TO WONDER THE OBVIOUS.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY ISN’T BAD
ENOUGH FOR SANDERS TO ATTACK IT
AND WHY DO WE NEED A REVOLUTION?
SANDERS NEVER ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AND NOW HE NEVER WILL
BECAUSE UNDERNEATH IT ALL HE WAS
A PARTY MAN TO THE CORE ALWAYS.
SAD.
ALL OF WHICH MEANS JOE BIDEN IS
NOW THE PRESUMPTIVE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
NO ONE REALLY CHOSE BIDEN FOR
THIS JOB, HE WOUND UP IN IT BY A
SERIES OF DEFAULTS AND IT SHOWS.
ASK YOURSELF, IS JOE BIDEN READY
TO LEAVE THIS COUNTRY?
COULD HE FIND HIS CAR IN A
THREE-TIERED PARKING GARAGE?
COULD HE NAVIGATE A SALAD BAR?
AND BY THE WAY, WHAT EXACTLY IS
HIS POSITION ON THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC?
THOSE ARE THE MYSTERIES
DEMOCRATS NOW FACE.
BIDEN HAS BEEN VIRTUALLY
INVISIBLE FOR THE LAST MONTH.
THAT’S NOT AN ACCIDENT.
JOEJOE BIDEN ON CAMERA MEANS MOR
MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
>> WE’VE NEVER ALLOWED ANY
CRISIS FROM THE CIVIL WAR ALL
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC OF 1716, WE
HAVE NEVER, EVER LET OUR
DEMOCRACIES SAME SECOND FIDDLE.
WE CAN HAVE BOTH A DEMOCRACY AND
ELECTIONS ARE NOT THE SAME TIME
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
>> Tucker: DID YOU FOLLOW
THAT?
CORRECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE A MAN LIKE
THAT MAKING IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH A DEMOCRATIC DEBATE OR
EVEN STAYING AWAKE.
IT’S LIKELY THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS WILL FIND A WAY TO
REPLACE BIDEN.
WHATEVER HAPPENS, IT’S WORTH
TAKING JOE BIDEN SERIOUSLY FOR
THIS MOMENT.
NOW THAT HE IS OFFICIALLY IN A
SENSE THE NOMINEE.
BIDEN WAS FIRST ELECTED TO THE
SENATE AND THAT WAS
RICHARD NIXON OPENING TO CHINA
FROM THE WEST.
AS I GREW MUCH MORE OBVIOUS OVER
THE DECADES, BIDEN SEEMED TO
GROW MUCH MORE ACCOMMODATING TO
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
IN 2,000 THE U.S. AND CHINA
TRADE RELATIONS ACT GAVE CHINA
TRADE STATUS.
ROSEMARY DIXON DETAILS HOW THAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION OPEN THE
FLOODGATES FOR CHINESE DRUG
IMPORTS.
WITHIN THREE YEARS OF THE BILL
PASSING AMERICA LOST ITS LAST
ASPIRIN FACTORY AND ITS LESS
VITAMIN C FACILITY AND LAST
PENICILLIN PLANT.
OUR ABILITY TO MAKE CRITICALLY
VITAL ANTIBIOTICS IN THE CITY
VANISHED.
THAT WAS A BLOW TOWARDS NATIONAL
SECURITY.
AND YET JOE BIDEN VOTED FOR THAT
BILL.
WENT ON TO OPPOSE HIM AND THAT’S
TWO AT THE PUT PRESSURE ON CHINA
TO STOP FORCED ABORTIONS.
A YEAR LATER IN 2011, JOE BIDEN
STILL DIDN’T SEE THE THREAT.
THAT YEAR HE SAID, A RISING
CHINA IS A POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT
OF NOT ONLY FOR CHINA BUT FOR
AMERICA.
THE DAY THAT BIDEN GAVE THAT
SPEECH, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS.
CHINESE STUDENTS WERE ALREADY
FLOODING AMERICA’S SCHOOLS AND
RESEARCH LABS AND CROWDING OUT
AMERICANS, AND THAT WILL BOOST
THE ECONOMY LARGER THAN IT
STANDS TODAY.
BIDEN SAID THAT BUT IT WASN’T
THE ONLY TIME HE DID.
HERE WAS UP BIDEN LAST MAY ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> CHINA IS GOING TO EAT OUR
LUNCH.
COME ON, MAN.
THEY ARE NOT BAD FOLKS, BUT THEY
ARE NOT IN COMPETITION FOR US.
SPEED LIMIT JUST TWO MONTHS AGO,
WHEN IT WAS ALREADY CLEAR TO
EVERYONE THAT WAS WATCHING THAT
CHINA HAD LIED TO THE WORLD IN
WAYS THAT HURT THE WORLD, BIDEN
WAS STILL FLOCKING FOR THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE RIGHT NOW A CRISIS
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS AND FROM
CHINA.
THIS IS WHERE THE CREDIBILITY OF
THE PRESIDENT IS MOST NEEDED AS
HE EXPLAINS WHAT HE WE SHOULD AN
SHOULD NOT DO.
THIS IS NO TIME FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD OF
HYSTERIA -- HISTORICAL
XENOPHOBIA AND FEARMONGERING TO
LEAD THE WAY, INSTEAD OF SCIENCE
SCIENCE.
>> Tucker: XENOPHOBIA, IT
SEEMS ALMOST ANTIQUE.
WHY?
BECAUSE IN A MOMENT LIKE THIS, A
MOMENT OF NATIONAL CRISIS,
IRRELEVANT ISSUES TEND TO
RECEDE.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD RECENTLY
ABOUT HOW AMERICA IS RACIST AND
WE NEED REPARATIONS FOR SLAVERY
AND NONBINARY SIGNS IN MEN’S
RESTROOM STALLS.
IT ALL SEEMS FRIVOLOUS NOW AND
MOMENTS LIKE THIS ARE THE BIG
THINGS.
AT THE TOP OF THIS LIST, WHO